We like to believe that there are laws among thieves. We like to believe that there are rules of honor, that when Michael Corleone orders a mob hit, it's because some code has been violated, that if Tony Soprano chokes a guy to death in a parking lot, it is because that guy broke some rule, that he deserved it somehow. This is one of the most romantic ideas that we have about crime, that there could be a system, that there could be ancient, strict rules, and that there are people out there who actually try to follow those rules, you know?
我们愿意相信盗亦有道。我们愿意相信存在某种荣誉准则，认为当迈克尔·柯里昂下令帮派谋杀时，那是因为某种准则被触犯了；认为当托尼·索普拉诺在停车场勒死一个人时，是因为那个人破坏了某种规矩，他罪有应得。这是我们对犯罪最浪漫的构想之一：即犯罪可能存在一套体系，存在古老而严格的规则，并且真的有人在尝试遵循这些规则，你知道吗？
And at one level, of course we want to believe that. Of course we want to believe that it's all so orderly, rather than the thing that we fear about crime, which is that it's random and can strike us at any time, that it's senseless. If there's a system, if there are rules, if it's a business, it doesn't even seem like crime.
在某种程度上，我们当然愿意相信这一点。我们当然愿意相信这一切都是如此井然有序，而不是我们对犯罪最恐惧的那面——即犯罪是随机的，随时可能降临到我们头上，它是毫无意义的。如果存在一套体系，如果存在规矩，如果它是一门生意，那它看起来甚至就不像是犯罪了。
Well, it turns out that there's a classic American primer about the laws of pimps and pimping written in 1968, Iceberg Slim's Pimp: The Story of My Life . In it, Iceberg Slim explains the rules of being a successful pimp. It is such a clearly-defined tradition, the way he tells it, that at one point, he visits an older pimp for advice. And the guy doesn't just give him the advice. He begins by laying out the entire history of pimping in the Americas. And then he gives him the pointers on how to pimp by the book.
事实证明，1968年出版的一本关于皮条客和拉皮条法则的经典美国入门书——冰山斯利姆（Iceberg Slim）所著的《皮条客：我的一生》——解释了成为一名成功皮条客的规则。他所讲述的这种传统有着非常明确的定义，以至于有一次，他去请教一位老皮条客。而那个人不仅给了他建议，还先为他梳理了美洲拉皮条行业的全部历史。然后，他才向他传授了如何按规矩拉皮条的诀窍。
"By the book" is always said in this reverential way when you read Iceberg Slim. "By the book" means, when it comes to pimping, knowing that you're using people, outmaneuvering them when they try to play you, and never getting sentimental about it. It's business.
当你读冰山斯利姆的书时，“按规矩”总是以一种虔诚的方式被提及。在拉皮条的语境下，“按规矩”意味着：你知道自己在利用别人，在她们试图算计你时胜过她们，并且永远不要对此产生感情。这就是生意。
Today on our program, a former pimp makes the case that in Oakland, California, in the 1970s, in the last heyday of American pimps in a stronghold of American pimping, the rules of the game that Iceberg Slim describes were not just a reassuring fiction but a way of life for hundreds of people, maybe thousands.
今天在我们的节目中，一位前皮条客提出，在20世纪70年代的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市——那个美国皮条客鼎盛时期的重镇——冰山斯利姆所描述的游戏规则不仅仅是一种让人安心的虚构，而是成百上千，甚至上万人的一种生活方式。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Most weeks on our program, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today, instead, we are devoting our entire program to just one story of a man who tried to be a pimp, found out he did not have the stomach for the violence, and how that let to his downfall in the pimping world.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和公共广播国际的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们节目都会设定一个主题，为你带来与该主题相关的各种故事。但今天，我们将整个节目献给一个男人的故事：他曾试图成为一名皮条客，却发现自己受不了其中的暴力，而这也导致了他后来在皮条客世界中的没落。
Today's show is the story of him and his friends and his observations about the rules of the game on the street back then. I have to say, part of what's amazing about him is the detail that he gets to in describing how that world worked. Our program today, Pimp Anthropology. Act One, Rules of the Game. Act Two, The Price of Ignoring the Rules. Stay with us.
今天的节目讲述了他和他的朋友们，以及他对当时街头游戏规则的观察。我必须说，他令人惊叹的地方之一，在于他描述那个世界运作方式时所展现的细节。我们今天的节目名为《皮条客人类学》。第一幕：游戏规则。第二幕：无视规则的代价。请继续收听。
The guy who is the subject of our show today spoke with Tamar Brott, a writer in California who he's known for years. I should say before we begin that if you are listening with small children, there is no sex in today's show. None at all. No graphic descriptions, no sex acts are even named, though there is a scene or two where men hit women. Well, here's Tamar Brott.
今天我们节目的主角与加利福尼亚州的作家塔玛·布罗特进行了交谈，他们相识多年。在开始之前我得说明，如果您带着年幼的孩子收听，今天的节目中没有性描写。完全没有。没有露骨的描述，甚至没有提及性行为，尽管有一两个男人殴打女人的场景。好的，下面请听塔玛·布罗特的讲述。
When Kevin was growing up in Oakland, he and his childhood friends Mark, Keith, and Little Ricky decided they were going to be pimps. And that's what they became. This was in the '70s, and the city was overrun with pimps.
当凯文在奥克兰长大时，他和儿时好友马克、基思和小瑞奇决定要成为皮条客。他们后来也确实走上了这条路。那是在70年代，城市里到处都是皮条客。
The vice cops say that Oakland had the largest prostitution trade in all of California. The infrastructure was perfect-- plenty of freeway access to cheap motels, and lots of places for the pimps to shop. They went to Hill's Shoes for their footwear, Olsen's Cadillac for their custom cars, and Wilson's House of Leather for their clothes. At the height of his glory, Kevin wore a gold lame suit with beaver fur collar and cuffs. Mark favored a long, white, leather coat. Keith was partial to jewel-encrusted dollar signs. This is their story.
风化案警察说，奥克兰拥有整个加利福尼亚州最大的卖淫交易。基础设施非常完美——有通往廉价汽车旅馆的高速公路，还有很多皮条客消费的地方。他们去希尔鞋店买鞋，去奥尔森凯迪拉克买定制车，去威尔逊皮革店买衣服。在凯文最风光的时候，他穿着金色的金属丝西装，领口和袖口饰有海狸皮毛。马克偏爱长款白色皮大衣。基思则喜欢珠宝镶嵌的美元符号。这就是他们的故事。
Where I was raised, a lot of kids, we looked at role models. Just as they do today, look at athletes today. Well, back then, one of the first images of success that you would see were Cadillacs. That was a sign of success for people in poor and blighted areas, especially in housing projects.
在我长大的地方，很多孩子都会寻找榜样。就像他们今天看待运动员一样。嗯，在当时，你看到的第一批成功形象就是凯迪拉克。对于贫困和落后地区的人们来说，这是一种成功的标志，特别是在廉价住房区。
One of my earliest memories was of a guy named Robert Charles. He was a local guy who had, at the time, what I thought was the greatest car in the world. He had a Cadillac that probably was a '60, '61 Cadillac. Brown. The car was beautiful. And he would ride through the neighborhood. And I didn't realize at the time that he was a pimp. But he'd ride through the neighborhood. He had the girls.
我最早的记忆之一是一个叫罗伯特·查尔斯的人。他是当地的一个人，在那时，他拥有我当时认为世界上最棒的车。他有一辆大概是60或61年的凯迪拉克。棕色的。那辆车真漂亮。他会开着车在街区穿行。我当时并不知道他是个皮条客。但他会开着车到处走，身边带着女孩。
And one of the things he'd always do was he would-- we'd have the ice cream truck that would roll through the neighborhood. He'd stop and get out, and he'd buy all the kids ice creams. So obviously, the image for us of Robert Charles was like, wow, this guy's really successful, he's got lots of money, and all of us aspired to be like Robert Charles.
他总是做的一件事是——我们街区会有冰淇淋车经过。他会停下来下车，给所有的孩子买冰淇淋。所以很明显，在我们眼中，罗伯特·查尔斯的形象就是：哇，这个人真的很成功，他有很多钱，我们所有人都渴望成为像罗伯特·查尔斯那样的人。
Right outside of Berkeley, on the Oakland border, is a hotel. It's called California Hotel. At that time, back in the '60s, it was, I'm guessing, a 600-room hotel, a really big hotel. Had a ballroom, a nightclub. At that time, Richard Pryor, who was just starting to burst on the national scene, was doing stand-up there. It reminds me of what I've read about what Harlem was like. It was an area where people who were black who were successful would go.
在伯克利外围，奥克兰的边界上，有一家酒店。叫加州酒店。在60年代那时候，我猜它有600间房，是一家非常大的酒店。有宴会厅，有夜总会。当时，刚开始在全国走红的理查德·普赖尔就在那里表演脱口秀。这让我想起我读到过的关于哈莱姆区的样子。那是一个黑人成功人士会去的地方。
Well, one of the things that happened was that whole California Hotel and the street San Pablo had become a red-light district. I remember the first time I rode down there, going down San Pablo and seeing all the girls-- dressed, standing on the corners, soliciting to the cars as they walked by, the short dresses, the skimpy outfits, everything.
嗯，发生的事情之一就是整个加州酒店和圣巴勃罗大街变成了一个红灯区。我记得第一次开车经过那里，沿着圣巴勃罗大道看去，看到所有的女孩们——盛装打扮，站在街角，向过往的车辆招揽生意，穿着短裙、暴露的服装，应有尽有。
And every pimp who was ever a pimp in the whole area drove up and down this street. They drove up and down this drill. And at that point, it's really funny, because it's different now. I don't think a pimp would want to be out there now. They sort of want to stay in the background. But then, you wore it like a badge of honor.
而且在该地区的所有皮条客都会开着车在那条街上反复兜圈。他们在那条“演习线路”上来回行驶。现在想来真是有趣，因为现在情况不同了。我想现在的皮条客不会想在大庭广众之下抛头露面。他们更倾向于隐藏在幕后。但在当时，你把它当作一种荣誉勋章。
When we originally began going down there, keep in mind, we were catching the bus there. We would just go down there and get the bus. AC Transit. We would get down there, we'd get off the bus, and we would just walk around. We might tease the girls, hey, how you doing honey? What's up? Where's your man at? He'll be back in 15 minutes. Just jiving-- shuckin' and jivin', as they call it-- with the girls. You've got to keep in mind, now, we're going down there, but at the same time, we're going back to school the next day.
当我们最初开始去那里的时候，要记住，我们当时还是坐公交车去的。我们只是坐公交车去那里。AC公交。我们下车后，就会在那儿四处溜达。我们可能会调侃那些女孩，“嘿，你好吗宝贝？怎么了？你的男人在哪儿？”“他15分钟后回来。”就这样调情——用他们的话说叫“闲扯”——和女孩们聊天。你要记住，虽然我们去那里，但同时我们第二天还要回学校上课。
One thing about Keith is that Keith, at some point, made a decision that that was more important to him, to be successful at that, than anything else. He made the step that none of the others were willing to make, and that was to drop out of school. His first thing was that, I've got to get me a car. I've got to get me a car. I've got to have flash. I've got to have something to show.
关于基思的一点是，基思在某个时刻做出决定，对他来说，在拉皮条上取得成功比任何事情都重要。他迈出了其他人都不愿迈出的一步，那就是辍学。他的第一件事就是，我得弄辆车。我得弄辆车。我得有派头。我得有东西来展示。
I remember Keith, he couldn't afford a Cadillac. So what he had was a Ford. He had, I think, a Ford Falcon. It was a convertible, though. And here's what he did. He painted it red, bright red. And he had the convertible top taken off-- it was a black convertible top-- and he had a white convertible top put on it. I mean, this was a car that he probably paid $400 for, or something like that. But when he finished it, it looked shiny and new.
我记得基思，他买不起凯迪拉克。所以他有一辆福特。我想是福特猎鹰（Ford Falcon）。不过是敞篷的。这就是他做的：他把它漆成了红色，鲜红色。他拆掉了敞篷车顶——原本是黑色的——换上了一个白色的敞篷车顶。我的意思是，这辆车他大概只花了400美元左右。但当他折腾完时，它看起来光鲜亮丽，像新的一样。
And boy, I'll tell you, he'd be riding up and down there. We'd be in the car with him. We would be riding up and down San Pablo. And he'd be in this little, red Ford, which was unheard of. Nobody even went down there in a Ford, but he was bold and brash enough to do that and do it with confidence. It was almost like he was saying, well, look, this is just my little sporty car. I've got a new Rolls Royce at home.
天哪，我告诉你，他会开着车在街上转来转去。我们坐在他车里。我们会在圣巴勃罗大道上来回兜风。他开着这辆红色的小福特，这简直闻所未闻。没人会开福特去那儿，但他足够大胆、足够狂妄，并自信地做到了这一点。那感觉就像他在说：“看，这只是我的运动小车。我家里还有辆劳斯莱斯呢。”
So the next thing that Keith needed to do was-- what every pimp needs-- is he needs a girl. You've got to have a girl. I mean, you can have the cars, you can have the clothes, but you have to have a girl. Keep in mind, too. At that point, the area that we were going was so established, you either knocked-- when they say "knocked," pulled some other man's girl-- or you turned a girl out, which would mean that you would introduce her to that whole lifestyle.
所以基思接下来的需要就是——每个皮条客都需要的东西——他需要一个女孩。你必须得有个女孩。我的意思是，你可以有车，可以有衣服，但你必须得有个女孩。也要记住一点，当时我们去的那个区域非常成熟，你要么去“敲诈”——所谓敲诈就是抢走别人的女孩——要么就是“开发”一个女孩，这意味着你要把她带入那种生活方式。
For Keith and us, it was about turning a girl out. That's how Keith got started. He turned out his girlfriend, who had been his longtime girlfriend anyway. Here's how it's introduced to her. One day, Keith is at his house, and we're all laughing and joking and having a drink or whatever. And he goes into the room and he says to her, you know what, Mark's a little drunk. He wants to go to bed with you. I told him to give me $50 and I'd ask you. She's like, no, I don't want to do like this.
对于基思和我们来说，关键在于“开发”一个女孩。基思就是这样开始的。他开发了自己的女朋友，反正那也是他交往很久的女友。这就是她被带入的过程：有一天，基思在家里，我们都在大笑、开玩笑、喝酒什么的。他走进房间对她说：“你知道吗？马克喝多了。他想和你上床。我告诉他给我50美元，我就去问你。”她说：“不，我不想这样做。”
But suddenly, he's talking her into it. Well, you know, it's only Mark. It's not a big deal. We could use the $50, you know what I mean? We could go do something, go out to dinner, go buy you a dress, or something like that. You take the money. I don't want it. You can go buy yourself something with it. So suddenly, this girl is now saying, well, OK, it's only Mark. I kind of know Mark. He's not a bad guy. OK, I'll do it. Well, you see, once you do that, once you sell yourself for money, it becomes very easy to do it again.
但很快，他开始说服她。好吧，你知道，那只是马克。没什么大不了的。我们可以用这50美元，你明白吗？我们可以去干点别的，出去吃顿晚餐，给你买件裙子，之类的。你拿着钱。我不想要。你可以去买点东西。所以突然间，这个女孩现在说：“好吧，那只是马克。我认识马克。他不是个坏人。好吧，我做。”你看，一旦你这样做，一旦你为了钱出卖自己，再做第二次就变得非常容易了。
You're there when he pulls this sting on her. Did you feel any sort of pity? Or what did you feel for her, knowing that a door had been opened for her that she would probably go into?
当他设下这个圈套时你在场。你有没有感到一丝怜悯？或者作为旁观者，你知道她从此开启了一扇通往不归路的大门，你当时是什么感觉？
I thought it was great. I really thought it was great watching this guy work. I didn't think it was great to the extent that some girl was getting turned out. I thought it was great to the extent that all of a sudden, everything that those images that we had sought, that we had aspired to, all of it was suddenly happening. And I was actually having the opportunity to be a part of it.
我觉得很棒。看这个家伙运作，我真的觉得很棒。我并不是说因为有个女孩被“开发”了而觉得棒。我觉得棒是因为突然间，我们所追求的那些形象，我们所渴望的一切，突然间都实现了。而我竟然有机会亲身参与其中。
It's one thing to watch Robert Charles and his girls. But it's another thing to go through the evolutionary process to see a pimp, so to speak, being born as well as a prostitute. And that was my image at that time. I was excited. It was like, wow, this man is actually getting ready to do what we've only talked about. He's actually getting ready to really do it. And not only that, he's got a girl who made the first step. So it was exciting. We were all excited.
看罗伯特·查尔斯和他的女孩们是一回事。但亲眼见证一个皮条客的诞生过程，以及一个妓女的诞生，那是另一回事。这就是我当时的印象。我很兴奋。就像是：哇，这个男人真的要去做我们只在嘴上谈论的事情了。他真的要来真的了。不仅如此，他还有一个已经迈出第一步的女孩。所以这很令人兴奋。我们都很兴奋。
And after the fact-- and this is what really, I think, and truly makes for a great pimp-- the way that Keith made her feel afterwards. I remember very clearly that when we heard Mark and her come out of the room, we were kind of giggling, right? And I remember Keith getting very serious. He was very serious. He was like, man, cut that [BLEEP].
事后——我认为这才是真正让基思成为伟大皮条客的原因——基思在那之后对待她的方式。我清楚地记得，当我们听到马克和她从房间里出来时，我们还在咯咯笑，对吧？我记得基思变得非常严肃。他非常严肃。他说：“伙计，别再在那儿扯淡了。”
He didn't want her in any way to feel like she had been used. He gave her the money. He talked with her. He hugged her. He kissed her. He actually showed her a lot of love at that particular point. And I think that's one of the most significant things when you're turning a girl out. And she became quite a prostitute, as a matter of fact.
他不想让她觉得自己被利用了。他给了她钱。他和她交谈。他拥抱她。他亲吻她。他在那个特定的时刻真的给了她很多爱。我认为这就是“开发”女孩时最重要的环节之一。事实上，她后来变成了一名非常称职的妓女。
I asked Kevin how Mark knew how to turn out his own girlfriend like that. Kevin just said that's how it had always been done. That's how Iceberg Slim did it, and god knows how many pimps before him. The world of pimping is filled with many of these particular customs and bylaws.
我问凯文，马克是怎么知道该如何那样开发他自己的女朋友的。凯文只是说，这种事向来如此。冰山斯利姆是这么做的，天知道在他之前有多少皮条客是这么做的。拉皮条的世界充满了许多这类特定的习俗和不成文法。
There was a gentleman-like agreement, so to speak, that there was rules of the game. And this is the thing that's changed nowadays. Back then, there was a purity of it. It's almost like a love, like basketball, a love for the game itself. And as a result of these people having a love for a game, there was also rules. And there was street rules. And those rules was adhered like laws.
可以说存在一种绅士协定，即游戏规则。而这正是如今已经改变的地方。那时候，这其中有一种纯粹性。几乎像一种热爱，就像热爱篮球，对游戏本身的热爱。由于这些人对游戏的热爱，规则也就随之产生。那是街头规则。而这些规则像法律一样被遵守。
Because there was a game and because there was rules and laws, there was things that needed to be done. And if a girl didn't understand the rules and laws, then she could be in violation, or what they call "out of pocket" or "bitch being out of pocket."
因为有游戏，因为有规则和法律，所以有些事情是必须做的。如果一个女孩不理解规则和法律，那她就可能违规，或者被称为“越界”或“这个贱人越界了”。
Some of the rules are obvious. Every prostitute's supposed to have a pimp. Every pimp's supposed to give that prostitute a nightly quota to earn and not let her come in until she earns it. And it's all for him, 100%. A pimp is not like an agent who takes a cut. What he does do is pay all her expenses-- her food, rent, medical bills, outfits, everything. And he protects her territory.
有些规则是很明显的。每个妓女都应该有个皮条客。每个皮条客都应该给那个妓女定下每晚的收入额度，不挣够就不准回家。而且这一切都归他所有，百分之百。皮条客不像拿抽成的经纪人。他所做的是承担她所有的开销——饮食、房租、医药费、服装，什么都包。并且他负责保护她的地盘。
A girl didn't want to go down, say, for example, and start working somebody else's corner. When you start to do that, you start to be in violation of the game. And when you were in violation of the game-- it's really funny-- the whole small community would come down on you. So the other girls would turn against you as quick as the pimps would.
一个女孩不会想去，比如说，开始去抢别人的地盘干活。当你开始那样做，你就开始违反游戏规则了。而当你违反游戏规则时——这真的很有趣——整个小圈子都会来针对你。所以其他的女孩会像皮条客一样迅速地与你反目。
And then some of the rules are arcane, even chivalrous, like how a woman gets to choose any pimp she wants. It's called choosing or re-choosing. If the woman finds a better pimp than the one she has, she presents him with a wad of cash she's managed to withhold from the first pimp, sort of like a dowry. Then the new pimp goes to the old pimp and says, sorry, she's with me now. And the old pimp is just supposed to let her go. That's the rule.
还有一些规则是晦涩难懂的，甚至带有骑士精神，比如女性可以自由选择她想要的任何皮条客。这被称为“选择”或“重选”。如果女性发现了一个比现任更好的皮条客，她会呈上一笔她瞒着前任存下来的现金，就像嫁妆一样。然后新皮条客去找老皮条客说：“抱歉，她现在跟我了。”而老皮条客就该放手。这就是规矩。
What you want to do is you want to keep your manhood and your dignity intact. And that's basically what would happen, is a guy who was in the game would be man enough to say, look man, your woman chose me. And here's what's happening. I want to pick up her clothes. And it's really funny. I never really understood that part of it, but that seems to be part of the ritual, picking up of clothes as if those clothes really mattered. I think more than picking up the clothes, that was sort of this hidden way for men to say, look, we have to finalize this business that we have and move on from there.
你想做的是保持你的男子气概和尊严。基本会发生的是，一个圈内人会表现得足够男人，说：“看伙计，你的女人选择了我。事情就是这样。我想去取她的衣服。”这真的很有趣。我从未真正理解那部分，但这似乎是仪式的一部分，去取衣服，就好像那些衣服真的很重要一样。我想比起取衣服，那更多是男人之间的一种隐蔽方式，表示：“看，我们得结束我们之间的这笔生意，然后继续前进。”
But no pimp wants it to come to that. And if he suspects that one of his prostitutes is even thinking about leaving, there's a time-honored way to deal with that too.
但没有皮条客愿意走到那一步。如果他怀疑自己的妓女有离开的念头，也有应对这种局面的传统方式。
If you ever felt your girl might be getting ready to leave you, or that you're losing, or you're getting down, or one girl's left and you've got two left or you've got one left, well, you want to get on the road. What you do is pack them all in the car and say, look, we're going to travel for a while. And you get out of town, because it's very hard for them to leave you while you're out of town. You drive across state. I mean, I had a guy driving as far as Georgia and turn around and come back, just to stop a girl from leaving him. It gives them an opportunity to reaffirm their commitment to each other, so to speak. You see? They glue them back together.
如果你觉得你的女孩可能准备离开你，或者你在走下坡路，或者一个女孩走了，你只剩下两个或一个了，那么，你就要上路了。你要做的是把她们都塞进车里，说：“看，我们去旅行一阵子。”你离开城镇，因为当你在外地时，她们很难离开你。你开过州界。我的意思是，我见过有人一直开车开到佐治亚州再折返回来，仅仅为了阻止女孩离开他。这让她们有机会重申她们对彼此的承诺。你明白吗？他们把她们重新粘在一起。
So Mark was the second of Kevin's pals to turn out his girlfriend. And after that, he became a real player. He got chosen by this six-foot-tall cash cow named Sunny and hit the big time.
所以马克是凯文的伙伴中第二个开发自己女友的人。此后，他成了一个真正的玩家。他被这个六英尺高、像摇钱树一样的女孩桑尼选中，从此飞黄腾达。
Sunny was a very well-known prostitute in Oakland. And she was white, which was really unusual. She just liked him. And this girl made tons of money. Sunny's the kind of girl where you don't need five girls. If you've got one Sunny, you don't need five girls. And he got Sunny. And boy, that's like putting your name on the map. So Mark was the next one to go on to have some degree of success. And then Ricky-- we called him Little Ricky-- Little Rick went on to have some success. He had two, three girls.
桑尼是奥克兰非常著名的妓女。而且她是白人，这非常罕见。她只是看中了他。这个女孩挣了成吨的钱。桑尼属于那种你不需要五个女孩的类型。如果你有一个桑尼，你就不用五个女孩。他得到了桑尼。天哪，那就像让你的名字响彻江湖。所以马克是下一个取得一定成功的人。然后是瑞奇——我们叫他小瑞奇——小瑞奇也取得了一些成功。他有两三个女孩。
So Ricky, I remember-- I'm going to skip ahead a little bit now. But I remember he had finally got a couple girls, and he was making a little bit of money. And I remember one of the first things he did, he wanted to buy a Bentley. So he bought a Bentley. And Bentley-- those huge ones then. You know, the big-- sort of like they had in Burke's Law . Remember that show, Burke's Law with-- I forget. But that was the image.
所以瑞奇，我记得——我现在稍微跳过一点。我记得他终于有了几个女孩，挣了点钱。我记得他做的第一件事，就是想买辆宾利。所以他买了辆宾利。宾利——当时那些巨大的车。你知道，那种大的——就像他们在《伯克法》（Burke's Law）里看到的。还记得那个节目吗，那个……我不记得了。但那就是那个形象。
Anyway, I remember Ricky coming-- Ricky's probably like five foot one or five foot two. But I remember him coming down the street. He had just got this Bentley, and you could barely see his head over the steering wheel. It was the funniest thing I had ever seen in my life. But he drives up, and he gets out. The door is bigger than him. He gets out the door, he slams the door, and he says, man, how do you like my Bentley Rolls Royce? I just got it. Anyway, we talked.
不管怎样，我记得瑞奇走过来——瑞奇可能只有5英尺1英寸或5英尺2英寸。但我记得他走在街上。他刚买了这辆宾利，你几乎看不到他的头露在方向盘上面。那是我这辈子见过最滑稽的事。但他开过来，走下车。车门比他人都大。他下了车，砰地关上车门，说：“伙计，你喜欢我的宾利劳斯莱斯吗？我刚买的。”不管怎样，我们聊了聊。
But he's-- it's hard for me to describe him-- not flamboyant as Keith but very smooth, more family oriented, believe it or not. He was always interested in how long they were going to stay. He used to always say, hos come leaving. Bitches come leaving. How long are you going to stay? That was the thing. And his whole thing was creating a family atmosphere. So he always, actually, wanted to impregnate his girls so that they would have his child so that they would stay to create that family atmosphere. And he impregnated several of his girls, and they had kids. And he's young at this point. He was relatively young.
但他——我很难描述他——不像基思那样张扬，但非常圆滑，信不信由你，他更看重家庭。他总是关心她们会留多久。他总是说：“婊子们来来去去。烂货们来来去去。你要留多久？”那是他的口头禅。他整套东西就是营造家庭氛围。所以实际上，他总是想让他的女孩怀孕，好让她们有了孩子后就能留下，营造那种家庭氛围。他让他的好几个女孩怀孕了，她们都有了孩子。那时候他还很年轻。他相对比较年轻。
So after not too long a time, Kevin's three friends are living large. They've got the clothes, the cars, the stables. Meanwhile, Kevin still hasn't been able to turn out his childhood sweetheart. He's managing to keep up appearances by becoming a drug dealer, supplying his buddies with the vast amounts of cocaine they've begun using.
没过多久，凯文的三个朋友都过上了好日子。他们有了衣服、汽车、稳定的货源。与此同时，凯文仍然没能开发他的青梅竹马。他通过成为毒贩来维持体面，为朋友们供应他们开始大量使用的可卡因。
But pimps looked down on drug dealers for being low rent. And privately, Kevin begins having doubts about whether or not he has what it takes to be a pimp. Part of his problem is that he doesn't know if he can hit a woman, which is a chief requirement for being in the game. At a certain point, his friend Dwayne actually show him how it's done. A little warning-- this is probably the most disturbing story Kevin will tell this hour.
但皮条客看不起毒贩，认为他们是底层租户。私下里，凯文开始怀疑自己是否具备成为皮条客的条件。他的一部分问题在于，他不知道自己是否能打女人，而这是入行的基本要求。在某个时刻，他的朋友德韦恩亲自向他展示了这是怎么做到的。一个小警告——这可能是凯文今天讲述的最令人不安的故事。
Dwayne, at that time, who was another friend, his whole philosophy was that, look, if a girl wasn't acting right, you beat the hell out of her. Beat the bitch's ass, and she'd straighten up. And so he told me, he said, look, I'm going to show you how to handle this. So he goes and he grabs a coat hanger, much as I have now. And I can only sort of describe to you what you do. You grab the hook, the hanger part, and you grab the middle of the lower wire and just pull it straight out. And it will form sort of a straight sort of a--
德韦恩，当时，他也是另一个朋友，他的全部哲学就是：看，如果女孩表现不好，你就往死里打她。揍那个婊子一顿，她就会变乖。所以他告诉我，他说：“看，我要向你展示如何处理这个。”他去拿了个衣架，就像我现在拿的这个。我只能粗略描述一下你怎么做。你抓住钩子，就是衣架部分，然后抓住下面金属丝的中间，直接把它拉直。它就会形成一种笔直的——
This silhouette is like a baseball bat outline.
这个轮廓就像一个棒球棍的形状。
Yeah, pretty much. Well, at that point, Dwayne, he had two options, depending on how angry he was. He would beat his girls with this hanger just like this. Or if they had to go to work, what he would do is take a light towel and wrap it around the towel. That way, he could beat her, and it wouldn't necessarily leave marks. That way, she could go to work, and she didn't look all beat up. She could wear the skimpy clothes and still look pretty good if he managed to hit her on the lower thigh or something. But he'd try to hit her right on the buttocks with this thing.
是的，差不多。好吧，那时，德韦恩有两个选择，取决于他有多生气。他会用这个衣架这样抽打他的女孩。或者，如果她们必须去工作，他会拿一条薄毛巾包裹住衣架。那样的话，他可以打她，但又不至于留下明显的痕迹。这样她就能去上班了，看起来不会被打得鼻青脸肿。她可以穿那些暴露的衣服，只要他打在大腿根部之类的地方。但他会试着打她的臀部。
So one of my earliest visions was I remember Annie being in the back and me coming into Dwayne's house. And there was some commotion, and we set to talking. He told her just get out of here. And we sat down and we started talking. I think we were watching a game or something like that. And you can hear stuff being thrown and tossed in the back room. Obviously, Annie was upset about something.
所以，我最早的记忆之一是，我记得安妮在后面，我走进德韦恩的房子。里面一阵骚乱，我们开始说话。他告诉她滚出去。我们坐下来开始交谈。我想我们在看比赛之类的。你可以听到后面房间里有东西被扔来扔去。很明显，安妮因为某事很不高兴。
Anyway, at that point, Dwayne called her out of the room after going over and getting a coat hanger and straightening it out. And he says, "Annie, come here." And Annie's acting like she didn't [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. And he says, "Bitch, get your ass in here right [BLEEP] now." And he's yelling at the top of his voice. "Get your [BLEEP] ass in here. At this point, he tells this bitch, "Bend over right here. Drop your [BLEEP] pants."
不管怎样，就在那一刻，德韦恩在过去拿了一个衣架并拉直后，把她叫出了房间。他说：“安妮，过来。”安妮表现得好像她没听见。于是他说：“婊子，现在就给老子滚过来。”他扯着嗓子吼道，“把你的贱屁股给我挪过来。”他告诉那个婊子：“弯下腰，在这儿。把你的裤子脱了。”
I'm sitting there. I'm a bit stunned. I'm like, OK, we're going to roll with this. Annie comes over. At this point, when he flies into the tirade and he's yelling, "Bitch, get your ass over here," she's at attention. She comes right over, and he said, "Bitch, drop your mother [BLEEP] pants and bend over and grab your knees.
我坐在那儿。我有点震惊。我想，好吧，我们要演这出戏。安妮走了过来。在这一点上，当他大发雷霆吼叫着“婊子，把屁股挪过来”时，她立刻进入了状态。她走了过来，他说：“婊子，把裤子给老子脱了，弯下腰，抓住你的膝盖。”
And I'll never forget the look on her face. It was almost very robotic. But she walked right over at a point where she was acting wild and out of control. But there was a point that he reached when he started to talk to her that she snapped, and she just got very robotic, and he had total control over her. She walked over. And I swear, her ass couldn't have been three feet from my face.
我永远不会忘记她脸上的表情。那几乎是非常机械化的。但她走过来，刚才还在撒野，但在他开始跟她说话时，她瞬间就变了，变得非常机械，他完全控制了她。她走过去。我发誓，她的屁股距离我的脸绝对不到三英尺。
And she pulled her pants down, bent over, and grabbed her knees. And he whacked her with this clothes hanger right on her ass. And I mean, she was butt naked. No panties, no pants, no dress, no nothing. Butt naked.
她把裤子脱了，弯下腰，抓住自己的膝盖。他用那个衣架抽在她的屁股上。我是说，她当时一丝不挂。没穿内裤，没穿裤子，没穿裙子，什么都没穿。一丝不挂。
And he hit her with such force that the outline of that coat hanger was on her ass. And it cut her skin, and she bled. And as I was looking at her, when she pulled her pants down, it was clear that she had been beat like this before, because there were several black marks where they had healed from this coat hanger from previous beatings.
他打她的力气很大，那个衣架的轮廓都印在了她的屁股上。皮肤被划破了，她流血了。当我看着她，当她把裤子拉下来时，很明显她以前也被这样打过，因为那里有几块以前受罚留下的黑色伤痕。
At that point, he hit her again. And on the third time he went to hit her, I grabbed his hand. And I told him, I said, "Dwayne, that's enough. He said, "Man, this ho, she knows she out of line. Man, I'll beat this bitch's ass some more."
在那一刻，他又打了一下。当他第三次准备打的时候，我抓住了他的手。我对他说：“德韦恩，够了。”他说：“伙计，这烂货，她知道她越界了。伙计，我还要再揍这个婊子一顿。”
And at that point, I was saying, "Man, let's take care of some business." He said, "OK." He said, "Annie, pull your pants up." Even after I stopped him and we were talking, she was still standing there, bent over with her hands on her knees. He finally told her, "Annie, pull your pants and get your [BLEEP] ass out of here."
在那一刻，我说：“伙计，我们先谈谈正事。”他说：“好吧。”他说：“安妮，把裤子穿上。”即使在我阻止他之后，我们还在说话，她仍然站在那里，弯着腰，双手按在膝盖上。他最后告诉她：“安妮，穿上裤子，带着你的贱屁股滚出去。”
She pulled her panties up. White. It was just a really interesting image because when she pulled her panties up first, you could see the blood go right through her panties. So you could see the red soaking through her panties. She pulled her pants up, she walked in the back room, she was quiet like nothing happened. It was just incredible. And I thought to myself, the cruelty, I mean, to not have compassion for another person.
她拉起她的内裤。白色的。那是一个非常有趣的画面，因为当她先把内裤拉上时，你可以看到血直接渗过了内裤。所以你可以看到红色浸透了她的底裤。她穿上裤子，走进后屋，安静得就像什么都没发生一样。真是太不可思议了。我心想，这种残忍，我是说，对另一个人竟没有丝毫同情。
You know what's really funny? I didn't openly show any remorse about these girls. I didn't openly feel sorry for them. When Annie was getting a beating, and when I grabbed Dwayne's hand, my thing was, man, let's take care of our business. I didn't say it in a way that was like, man, give her a break. I said it in a very nonchalant way like, man, this bitch, I have no time for this [BLEEP]. Get this bitch out of here, and let's do what we going to do. I didn't show concern for Annie, you see?
你知道什么很有趣吗？我没有公开表现出对这些女孩的任何怜悯。我没有公开地为她们感到难过。当安妮挨打时，当我抓住德韦恩的手时，我的想法是：“伙计，我们先处理正事。”我说的并不是那种“伙计，放她一马吧”。我用一种非常随意的口吻说：“伙计，这个婊子，我没时间在这儿扯淡。赶紧让她滚出去，我们接着做我们要做的。”我没有表现出对安妮的关心，你明白吗？
Because these are internal conflicts that I'm having. Like all men, you don't ever want to appear less than. So though these issues are twirling around in my mind and they're starting to bother me, I'm not letting them be known. I'm happy for them still. These are just my own conflicts that I'm starting to have. So I'm still excited about the pimping. I'm still excited about the possibility that maybe, just maybe this stuff will pass for me. But deep down inside-- I think I even knew then-- deep down inside, it wouldn't, because I was a compassionate person. But I was hoping that it would.
因为这些是我内心经历的冲突。像所有的男人一样，你永远不想表现得不如人。所以，尽管这些问题在我脑海中盘旋并开始困扰我，但我没有表现出来。我依然为他们感到高兴。这些只是我自己开始产生的冲突。所以我仍然对这种拉皮条很兴奋。我仍然对这种可能性感到兴奋，也许，仅仅是也许，这种事也会发生在我身上。但内心深处——我想我当时甚至就知道——内心深处，那不会发生，因为我是个有同情心的人。但我还是希望它会发生。
Why did he do that in front of you?
他为什么要当着你的面做那件事？
I think part of it was psychologically to demonstrate his control over her. There was that aspect of it. That was for me. That was from him to me. But I think also, on the other hand, there was the breaking down of a person's constitution. When he's able to do that to her, eventually, at some point, she stops believing in herself, and she only believes in him. And so once you can get that transference, get a person so they have no self esteem left, no sense of self-worth left, then the only thing that they can do is believe in you. They start to associate their own sense of self-worth and self-esteem to the very person who took their own.
我想这部分是心理上的，为了展示他对比她的控制权。有那方面的因素。那是给我的。那是他展示给我看的。但我认为，另一方面，这也是为了粉碎一个人的意志。当他能对她那样做时，最终，在某个时刻，她会停止相信自己，而只会相信他。所以一旦你能得到那种心理转移，让一个人彻底丧失自尊，没有自我价值感，那么她们唯一能做的就是相信你。她们开始把自己的自我价值感和自尊心与那个夺走它们的人联系在一起。
And this goes directly to the attitude of why at some point, hos want to make their pimps the best pimp. They want them to have the biggest hat, the biggest Cadillac, the longest shoes, the longest coat. They want them to have this. Because in a sense, they live vicariously through that person. Their sense of self-esteem, their sense of self-worth is all incumbent upon how their man feels.
这就是为什么有时候婊子们想让她们的皮条客成为最棒的。她们想让他们戴最大的帽子、开最大的凯迪拉克、穿最长的鞋、披最长的皮草大衣。她们希望他们拥有这些。因为在某种意义上，她们通过那个人过着代理人生。她们的自尊感、自我价值感，全都取决于她们的男人感觉如何。
This is why pimps dress like pimps.
这就是为什么皮条客穿得像皮条客一样。
When you have a relatively small community-- and when I say a small community, I'm talking about pimps now-- a small community of men who are vying for attention of women, then it's all going to depend a lot on how much attention a guy can bring to himself. In a way, it's almost like what you could call a peacock syndrome. You know how peacocks, they have the plumage? The males have the plumage? And they can be kind of skirting around, and they're spreading their wings, and they're trying to get the attention of the female.
当你拥有一个相对较小的圈子——当我说是小圈子时，我是指现在的皮条客——一个为了争夺女性注意力而竞争的男人圈子，那么一切很大程度上将取决于一个人能带给自己多少关注。从某种意义上说，这就像所谓的“孔雀综合症”。你知道孔雀吗，它们有羽毛？雄性有羽毛。它们会走来走去，张开翅膀，试图吸引雌性的注意。
And in a lot of ways, pimps have that same kind of mentality. It's like, who has the brightest colors, the biggest hats, the most fur, the longest leather? I don't think they think in terms of whether this is, like how I will appear to the community as a whole. But rather they're making a statement to a very specific group of people-- i.e. being the pimps and all the hos.
在很多方面，皮条客也有同样的心理。就像是：谁有最亮的颜色、最大的帽子、最多的皮毛、最长的皮衣？我不认为他们会考虑自己作为一个整体在社区中看起来如何。而是他们正试图向一个非常特定的群体——即其他的皮条客和所有的婊子们——宣示主权。
I asked Kevin why the girls didn't just leave and strike out on their own. Why bother to have a pimp at all? He said prostitution's too territorial, and given the potential dangers of selling your body, it's good to have somebody on your side, even if it is a pimp. And in their own twisted way, they did provide some sense of family.
我问凯文，为什么女孩们不离开，自己闯荡？为什么要费力找个皮条客？他说卖淫太讲究地盘了，考虑到出卖肉体潜在的危险，身边有人支持还是好的，即使那个人是皮条客。而且以他们扭曲的方式，他们确实提供了一种家庭感。
The thing about it is, is that these were relationships. And I think that's what people forget or miss. It wasn't a business arrangement in the sense that I say to you, come work for me, and as a result, I'll give you 10%. These were relationships, much like families. People would say, come be a part of my family. You can be a part of my family. Now families, i.e., may mean stable. You can be a part of my stable of hos. But the fact of the matter is that that stable may be described as families.
关键在于，这些都是人际关系。我认为这是人们忘记或忽略的地方。这不是那种商业契约，比如我对你说：“来为我工作，作为回报，我给你10%。”这些是人际关系，非常像家庭。人们会说：“来成为我家庭的一部分吧。”你可以成为我家庭的一员。现在家庭，即意味着稳定。你可以成为我的“妓女马厩”的一员。但事实是，那个“马厩”可能被描述为家庭。
This is how we live. We have a house. We have a nice penthouse. We've got cars. I've got my cars, but oftentimes, the girls had cars too, to get back and forth to work. We've got all of this stuff. You don't have to worry about anything except for just working and being a part of the family.
我们就是这样生活的。我们有房子。我们有漂亮的顶层公寓。我们有车。我有我的车，但通常女孩们也有车，方便上下班。我们有这一切。你不需要担心任何事情，除了工作和成为家庭的一部分。
I think what confuses people is that people try and figure out how the girls have a single purpose of their own, in terms of acquiring money. But it was never like that. You moved in, you became a part of that whole exciting lifestyle that he would live in. And as a result, the money was really incidental to the lifestyle as a whole.
我认为让人困惑的是，人们试图搞清楚女孩们如何有自己的单一目标，即获取金钱。但从来不是那样的。你搬进去，你就成了他所生活的整个令人兴奋的生活方式的一部分。因此，钱对于整个生活方式来说真的只是次要的。
Do you think women who go into prostitution, there's something that happens at like, what, age of 10? When does it set in that this self-esteem issue--
你认为从事卖淫的女性，在10岁左右发生了什么？什么时候这种自尊问题——
What I would say was that a person who has issues of self-worth and low self-esteem would probably be a better candidate to become a ho, or a prostitute, than someone who didn't. Now, that sounds fairly obvious to anybody who would hear that. They'd say, well, that's pretty obvious. But the thing about it is, is that it's not something that people necessarily wear that's so obvious to see in a person. And so I think that's what makes some good pimps is the little probing of a person to find out where they're at.
我会说，一个在自我价值和自尊心方面有问题的人，可能比一个没有这些问题的人更适合成为妓女。现在，这对于听到的人来说听起来相当显而易见。他们会说：“好吧，那太明显了。”但问题是，这并不是人们必须穿在身上显而易见的。所以我认为这就是为什么一些好的皮条客会通过一点点的探查来了解一个人的底细。
I'll give you an example of a very simple probe a friend of mine used to do. He'd be in a club, and he'd meet a girl. And he would go up, and let's say he's having a cocktail. She's sitting at the counter next to him. And he would, after a bit of banter and small talk and conversation, he'd say, buy me a drink. Now obviously, some girls would automatically say, buy your own drink. Or you buy me a drink. But some women would buy him a drink.
我给你举一个我朋友过去常用的简单试探的例子。他在俱乐部里，会遇到一个女孩。他会走过去，假设他正在喝鸡尾酒。她坐在旁边的柜台。在一番打趣、闲聊和谈话后，他会说：“给我买杯酒。”现在显然，有些女孩会自动说：“你自己买酒。”或者“你给我买杯酒。”但有些女人会给他买酒。
That's the little kind of probing stuff that people do. You see, because just through five minutes of little conversation, now all of a sudden, he's seeing that he can exert his will over this woman, that she, not even in a conscious way, is basically giving in to his will. And sometimes it's that simple, something as small as that.
这就是人们所做的那种小试探。你看，因为仅仅通过五分钟的小谈话，现在突然间，他看到他可以对这个女人施加他的意志，她甚至不是在有意识的情况下，基本上屈服于他的意志。有时事情就是这么简单，小到那种地步。
Coming up, a prostitute who likes to talk a lot, Kevin's own rise and fall as a pimp, and whatever happened to all of the '70s pimps. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，一个话很多的妓女，凯文作为皮条客的起起落落，以及70年代所有的皮条客到底发生了什么。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自公共广播国际的节目将为您呈现。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Most weeks on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of stories on that theme. Today, we're devoting our entire show to one story about pimps in the 1970s. After that era, this particular culture of pimping died off. But the pimps of that era-- with the flashy clothes, the big hats, the pretty shoes-- they had become American icons, like cowboys or astronauts. Kevin's story continues.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们节目当然会选择一个主题，带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天，我们将整个节目献给一个关于70年代皮条客的故事。那个时代之后，这种特定的拉皮条文化消亡了。但那个时代的皮条客——有着华丽的衣服、大帽子、漂亮的鞋子——他们已经成为了美国的标志，就像牛仔或宇航员一样。凯文的故事继续。
My experience was that I met a girl. Her name was Lois. I remember Lois. She was tall, beautiful, brunette, about six feet tall. Just gorgeous. Just a gorgeous girl. And I remember that I was familiar with the game. I didn't want to lead on to her that I was, but nor did she want to lead on to me that she was. I had always aspired to be a pimp and was familiar with the game and knew how it went. I knew she was a ho, but I was going to never approach her like that. And I knew she was struggling to tell me, because she was trying to feel me out.
我的经历是，我遇到了一个女孩。她的名字叫洛伊斯。我记得洛伊斯。她又高又漂亮，棕色头发，大约六英尺高。简直美极了。就是一个绝美的女孩。我记得我很熟悉这个游戏。我不想让她看出我也懂，她也不想让我看出她懂。我一直渴望成为一名皮条客，熟悉这个游戏，也知道它是怎么回事。我知道她是个妓女，但我永远不会那样去接近她。我知道她在挣扎着想告诉我，因为她在试探我。
So she finally got around, she says, "Well, why don't you come by my job, come down to my house?" She was staying over in Belmont at the time. "Come down for the weekend. Spend the weekend at my place." She had been to my place several times. We had dinner in the city and stuff. And so I said, "OK, I'll do that."
所以她终于绕到那儿了，她说：“好吧，为什么你不到我的工作地点来看看，到我家去？”她当时住在贝尔蒙特。周末过来吧。在我的住处过周末。她去过我家好几次了。我们在城里吃过饭之类的。所以我说：“好的，我会那样做的。”
So it was very clever how she did this. It was really funny. But she wanted to see how I played this out. So she told me to come and get her. "Come by my job and get my key, and then you can just go to the house. I've got food and everything there. You can get yourself something to eat and just wait. And I'll be there in a few hours. So I said, OK, it's on, so to speak. So I'm thinking to myself, OK, it's on.
她这样做非常聪明。这真的很有趣。但她想看看我如何处理这个。所以她让我去接她。“到我工作的地方拿我的钥匙，然后你就可以直接去房子。那儿有食物和其他东西。你可以自己拿点吃的等着。几个小时后我就到。”所以我说：“好的，那说定了。”所以我心想，好的，开始了。
So I pull in the back of this place. And as it turns out, it's a massage parlor. So I pull up in back, and I go and I parked, and I called her. I said, "Lois, I'm here in back." So she comes out, and she's dressed normally. She's got on a nice silk dress and everything. She jumps in the car. She gives me a big kiss. "Oh, I'm so glad. This is going to be so exciting. I can't wait to get home. And here's the keys."
于是我把车开进那个地方的后面。结果证明，那是一家按摩院。所以我开进去停好车，给她打电话。我说：“洛伊斯，我在后面。”她出来时打扮得很正常。她穿着漂亮的丝绸裙子什么的。她跳进车里。给我一个大大的吻。“哦，我太高兴了。这会很刺激的。我迫不及待想回家了。这是钥匙。”
And I say OK, give her a peck on the cheek, and I'm about to pull out. And she says, "Oh, by the way, take this home for me." And she hands me an envelope full of cash. Obviously, I don't think this was a day's wages. I think she had probably not been with somebody for a while, and she had been saving her money up. Had about $2,500 in cash in it. And to me, I mean this looked like $100,000 to me. I was like, whoa, OK.
我说好的，亲了亲她的脸颊，准备开车走。她说：“哦，顺便提一下，帮我把这个带回家。”她递给我一个装满现金的信封。显然，我不认为这是一天的工资。我觉得她可能有一段时间没跟人待在一起了，她把钱存了下来。里面大概有2500美元现金。对我来说，这看起来像10万美元。我当时想：“哇，好的。”
But she didn't give it to me, though. She says, "By the way, can you take this to my house for me?" So she hands me this money. I'm looking at this money, and I said, "Sure." So I close the envelope, and I go to her house.
但她没把钱给我，她说：“顺便问一下，你能把它带到我家吗？”她递给我这笔钱。我看着这些钱，说：“当然。”所以我合上信封，去了她家。
Later, she finally makes it home. She calls me. She says, "there's wine there. Have some wine." Blah, blah, blah. She's got champagne. She's got the whole-- I mean, it's obviously a setup. The flowers-- there was a place called Ah Sam's. They imported flowers from Hawaii, the most exotic flowers. And she had these exotic flowers from Ah Sam's all over the house, easily $500 worth of flowers.
后来，她终于到家了。她给我打电话。她说：“那儿有酒。喝点酒。”巴拉巴拉。她有香槟。她有全套——我的意思是，这显然是一个精心布置的局。鲜花——有个叫阿三（Ah Sam's）的地方。他们从夏威夷进口花卉，最奇异的花。她屋子里到处都是这些阿三的奇异花卉，至少价值500美元。
So what ended up happening was she ended up getting here about 6:30, 7:00. She comes in. And we sit down, and we're having wine, and we're talking and just sort of chatting. And she looks at me and she smiles, and I said to her, I said, "Oh, by the way. I put your money over on your nightstand by your bed." And she said to me, "Oh, no. You can keep it. It's for you."
结果就是她大概6:30、7:00才到。她进来了。我们坐下来，喝着酒，聊天。她看着我笑，我对她说：“哦，顺便说一下。我把你的钱放在床边的床头柜上了。”她对我说：“哦，不。你可以留着它。它是给你的。”
And I looked at her, and I kind of smiled, and I said, "What exactly is it that you do?" And she just looked at me and smiled, and she said, "You know damn well what I do." And we just started laughing at each other. And from that point on, we stayed together for, I guess, about seven years. Seven years.
我看着她，笑了笑说：“你到底是做什么的？”她只是看着我笑了笑说：“你心里清楚我干什么的。”我们开始相对大笑。从那一刻起，我们在一起待了大概七年。七年。
I remember being in the Black Knight, as a matter of fact, with a group of people. And one of the things about Lois was that she was fairly articulate for a working girl. And we would have lively conversations, me and her. That was one of the things that we enjoyed. We would have lively conversations. Well, one of the things was that, when you were sitting with a group of guys, then every ho in the place is taking second position to their man. And so they basically are at this point where they don't speak until they're spoken to.
事实上，我记得曾在黑骑士俱乐部和一群人在一起。洛伊斯的一点是，对于一个工作中的女孩来说，她口才很好。我们俩会进行生动的交谈。这是我们喜欢的事情之一。我们会进行生动的交谈。嗯，其中一点是，当你和一群男人坐在一起时，地方上的每个妓女都排在她们男人之后。所以她们基本上在那个时刻不会说话，除非被问到。
And so when I come in with Lois, she's disrupting this whole [BLEEP] thing. I mean, she's [BLEEP] all this [BLEEP] up. Because you know what? Because I'm talking [BLEEP], and then she's talking [BLEEP] too. You know what I mean? And she's not waiting for me to stop to give her the OK to talk [BLEEP]. She's talking [BLEEP] as a separate entity all unto herself. And not only is she talking [BLEEP], but she'll talk to some other man. Do you see what I'm saying? Like some other pimp sitting there.
所以当我带着洛伊斯进来时，她打破了这一切烂摊子。我的意思是，她把这一切搞砸了。因为你知道吗？因为我在扯淡，然后她也跟着扯淡。你明白我的意思吗？她没有等我停下来给她开口的信号。她作为一个独立的个体在说话。不仅如此，她还会和别的男人说话。你明白我的意思吗？比如坐在那儿的另一个皮条客。
So you see, I wasn't just treating her as  a ho. I was treating her, to some degree, as a partner to me. So our relationship was different, and that created a definite conflict when we're sitting around a table with a bunch of pimps and a bunch of hos who won't even say nothing unless they're spoken to. And then this bitch is running her mouth 90 miles an hour talking [BLEEP] about the same [BLEEP] that we're talking about. Every ho in the joint is looking at her saying, who the [BLEEP] is this bitch? You know I mean? This bitch is out of line. He need to slap that bitch in the mouth and make her shut up.
所以你看，我不只是把她当成妓女。在某种程度上，我把她当作我的伙伴。所以我们的关系与众不同，当我们和一群皮条客及一群甚至不敢吱声的妓女坐在一张桌子旁时，这造成了明确的冲突。然后这个贱人以90英里的速度谈论着同样的烂事。场子里的每个妓女都在看着她说：“这个贱人是谁？”你明白吗？“这个贱人越界了。他得扇那个贱人的嘴巴让她闭嘴。”
I actually used to get a kick out of it. I thought it was funny that she was spirited, like a horse. She was spirited and strong willed. And I actually liked that. But for a ho, that wasn't a very good trait to have. And so guys, they used to give me a hard time about that. They was like, man, if you're coming, leave that bitch at home. It got to that point. You know what I mean? Look, if you're coming, man, leave that bitch at home, man. Because that bitch is just disruptive to the game. It got where they didn't want her around their ho.
我以前真的很享受这种感觉。我觉得她像马一样有灵性很有趣。她很有灵性，意志坚定。我其实很喜欢那样。但对于一个妓女来说，那不是什么好特质。所以其他人会因此给我找麻烦。他们说：“伙计，你要是来，就把那贱人留在家里。”甚至到了那个地步。你明白我的意思吗？“看，伙计，如果你要来，把那贱人留在家里。因为那贱人对游戏干扰太大了。”最后他们甚至不想让她出现在他们的妓女身边。
Believe me, over the years I heard people say, man, that nigger ain't no pimp. You know what I mean? He ain't no pimp, you know what I mean? But I even got that from my friends, my best friends.
相信我，多年来我听到人们说：“伙计，那个黑鬼根本不是个皮条客。”你明白吗？“他根本不是个皮条客。”但我甚至从我的朋友，最好的朋友那里也听到过。
So they were critical of you and the way--
所以他们批评你和你的方式——
Sure.
当然。
So at this point, Kevin's become like the pimp who can't shoot straight. His friends keep berating him for fraternizing with Lois, for never giving her quotas. But most appalling is that Kevin's still dating his childhood sweetheart and buying her expensive gifts, all paid for with Lois' money.
所以到了这个时候，凯文成了一个“枪法不准”的皮条客。他的朋友们不断斥责他与洛伊斯过于亲近，从不给她定额。但最令人震惊的是，凯文仍然在和他的青梅竹马约会，并买昂贵的礼物给她，所有这些都是用洛伊斯的钱支付的。
This is the thing that the guys got on me the worst about. The guys said, look, what you're doing is wrong. Because what I would do-- Lois was probably making, like I said, between $400 and $600 in a day. I would shower this other girl with gifts. I mean, just spent incredible amounts of money on her. Diamond rings, gold necklaces. That was another thing the guys, as I said, used to get mad at me. Because they used to say, man, you're not being true to this ho. You know what I mean? You can't be spending this ho's money on this square girl unless this girl is paying you too, you know what I mean? [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
这就是让伙计们对我最反感的一点。伙计们说：“看，你做的是错的。”因为我会做的事——洛伊斯可能每天挣400到600美元。我会用礼物把这个女孩宠坏。我是说，真的花了大价钱在她身上。钻石戒指、金项链。正如我所说，这也是伙计们对我发火的另一件事。因为他们过去常说：“伙计，你对这个妓女不忠诚。你明白吗？你不能花这个妓女的钱去养那个清纯女孩，除非那个女孩也付钱给你。”
And that was one of the rules of the game. You can't be taking money from a ho and then spend it on a square broad, because then, in a way, you're being a trick, just like the trick who's spending money with your ho. You see? And so they didn't understand. This was like a total contradiction to them. It's like, how you going to be a pimp if she's getting money from tricks and then you turn around and being a trick?
那是游戏规则之一。你不能拿妓女的钱去养别的清纯女人，因为那样的话，在某种意义上，你就成了个“嫖客”，就像那个花钱在你妓女身上的嫖客一样。你明白吗？所以他们不理解。对他们来说，这完全是自相矛盾的。就像，“如果她从嫖客那里拿钱，而你回过头来自己成了嫖客，你算什么皮条客？”
We did have an occasion where Lois did something that was totally unacceptable. And at that time, she had left the house. And she had been gone for maybe a week or something like that. And this was totally unacceptable behavior in any relationship, let alone a pimp-ho relationship. So I'm at home, and I'm handling my business. And after a couple of days-- you stay up a couple of nights and you worry. But after a couple days, you get back to your routine. And you know, what the [BLEEP], it'll work itself out. But I remember her sort of waltzing in the house, and me and the boys is there just kicking it, right?
我们确实遇到过洛伊斯做了完全不可接受的事情的情况。当时，她离开了家。她大概走了一个星期左右。在任何关系中，这都是完全不可接受的行为，更不用说在皮条客与妓女的关系中了。所以我待在家里处理我的生意。几天后——你会熬夜担心。但几天后，你又回到了日常轨道上。你知道，“管他妈的，事情总会解决的。”但我记得她优雅地走进房子，我和伙计们正在那儿消遣，对吧？
And I remember her waltzing in the house like nothing happened. It was like, hey, how's it going? And she comes in, and she's heading to the kitchen. And I remember the guys was there. And so I felt like, to some extent, I had to do something. I had to act. I couldn't let her just arrogantly walk in like that with the guys sitting there. So I remember I wheeled around and I slapped her. I slapped her. And I slapper her hard. I mean, I slapped her real hard.
我记得她像没事儿一样优雅地走进来。就像是：“嘿，怎么样？”她进来了，朝着厨房走去。我记得那些伙计也在那儿。我觉得在某种程度上，我必须做点什么。我必须采取行动。我不能让她在那些家伙面前那么傲慢地走进来。所以我记得我转身扇了她一巴掌。我扇了她。我狠狠地扇了她一巴掌。
And when I slapped her, she fell to the ground. And she just laid there knocked out. She was knocked out. And I'm thinking to myself, jeez. Did she hit her head when she was going down? What is all of this about? So she's laying there. I remember looking around, and I think it was Mark who was there. And I remember, Mark looked at me, and he had this sort of look of disgust. Like, this bitch is just playing you like a [BLEEP] yo-yo.
当我扇她的时候，她摔倒在地上。她就这样昏死过去了。她昏过去了。我心想，天哪。她倒下去的时候撞到头了吗？这一切到底是怎么回事？她就躺在那儿。我记得环顾四周，我想是马克在那儿。我记得马克看着我，他露出一种厌恶的表情。就像是：“这个贱人简直把你像个溜溜球一样耍。”
And I'll tell you something really interesting. Almost without thought, I remember I had this pool stick in my hand. And I just whacked her across her back with this pool stick just about as hard as I could. It broke the pool stick in half. And let me tell you, I've never seen nobody jump up this quick in my life. This girl was like she was passed out. I've never seen nobody jump up so quick in my life.
我告诉你一件非常有意思的事。几乎没有思考，我记得我手里拿着这根台球杆。我用尽全力在那根台球杆上狠狠地抽在她的背上。它把台球杆打成了两截。让我告诉你，我这辈子从没见过有人跳起来这么快。这个女孩就像昏死过去一样。我这辈子从没见过有人跳起来这么快。
This girl jumped straight up off the floor and ran out the back door, through the kitchen, out the back door. I mean, she just jumped. It's almost like she had springs. And I remember Mark saying to me, "Man, that bitch is trying to play you." He said, "Man, that bitch you slapped, she was acting like she was knocked out. She was going to lay there all night if you'd have let her." He said, "Man, that bitch is playing on you." He said, "Kevin, you know what, man? You need to take care of that bitch, because that bitch is straight playing you."
这个女孩从地板上直挺挺地跳起来，从后门跑了出去，穿过厨房，跑出了后门。我是说，她就像有弹簧一样跳了起来。我记得马克对我说：“伙计，那个贱人在耍你。”他说：“伙计，你刚才扇的那个贱人，她是在装昏。如果你让她装，她能躺在那儿一整晚。”他说：“伙计，那个贱人在耍你。”他说：“凯文，你知道吗？你得好好管教那个贱人，因为她在赤裸裸地耍你。”
Would you have hit her if you were alone?
如果你是一个人，你会打她吗？
Initially, yeah, I probably would have. Yeah, I probably would have, only because I would have known that it was in order. It was what was in order. Yeah. It's almost like I had to. And she knew it.
起初，会的，我可能会。是的，我可能会，只是因为我会知道那是“该做的”。那是规矩。是的。几乎就像我必须这么做。而她也知道。
What was really funny was that later, she got bored. Because I lived a fairly normal life now, she got bored. But I remember one day, this guy I heard pulling up to my door and knocking on the door. And I look out and it's Lois. And she's got this guy with her. And he's a guy who, actually, I had known, I had seen around, who I knew to be a pimp named Jared.
真正有趣的是，后来，她厌烦了。因为我现在过着相当正常的生活，她觉得无聊了。但我记得有一天，我听到这家伙开车到我家门口敲门。我向外看，是洛伊斯。她带着这个家伙。他是个我实际上认识的人，我曾在周围见过，我知道他是个叫杰瑞德的皮条客。
And Jared says to me, "Look, let me talk to you for a minute." So he comes in and he says, "Look, man. Your ho, she re-chose. She's choosing me. She want to be with me now." He said, "I hope you don't have no problem with none of this, man. I just wanted to come to you man to man and let you know what time it is."
杰瑞德对我说：“看，让我跟你谈谈。”他走进来，说：“看，伙计。你的妓女，她重选了。她选择了我。她现在想跟我在一起。”他说：“我希望你对此没意见。我只是想以男人对男人的方式来通知你现在的情况。”
Now, it's really funny. As dignified and as much a part of the game that I had been, and as much as I had seen, at that point, I said to him, fine. I said, that's fine. I was real dignified. I said, that's fine. She can go. And I remember him saying, "She want to get her clothes." I said, that bitch can't get [BLEEP] out of my mother [BLEEP] house. Period.
现在，这真的很有趣。尽管我曾经那么有尊严，曾经那么深入地参与游戏，看过那么多场面，但在那一刻，我对他说：“好吧。”我说：“那很好。”我表现得非常有尊严。我说：“那很好。她可以走。”我记得他说：“她想取回她的衣服。”我说：“那个贱人别想从老子的房子里拿走任何一件该死的东西。没门。”
And it's really funny because, see, in the name of the game, I shouldn't have did that. I should've said, sure, go ahead. But at that point, even after all the training, after all the schooling, after all the being around, and after understanding how the game goes, at that point, I lost it. And I was like, no. You've got her, but the bitch can't have a [BLEEP] thing from me.
这真的很有趣，因为看，以游戏的名义，我不该那样做。我应该说：“好的，拿去吧。”但在那一刻，即使经过了所有的训练，经过了所有的教导，经过了所有的耳濡目染，了解了游戏规则之后，在那个时刻，我失控了。我就像是：“不行。你得到了她，但那个贱人别想从老子这儿带走任何一件狗屁东西。”
And it was really funny. It taught me something about the game, because when you're in violation of the game, the game will always come back and bite you. But I remember them leaving. And I remember them returning about 15 minutes later with the police. They came in, they took all her clothes, and they left. Now, you know what? They had every right to, because in the name of the game, I should've gave her stuff back anyway. But at that time, I was so angry she was reverting back. Because one of the things she had always said was that she was so glad that she didn't have a traditional pimp-ho relationship, that she didn't no longer want to be a part of that. But what she taught me was that she longed for it. She actually did miss it.
这真的很有趣。它教会了我一些关于游戏的道理，因为当你违反游戏规则时，游戏总会回来反咬你一口。但我记得他们离开了。我记得大约15分钟后他们带着警察回来了。他们进来，拿走了她所有的衣服，然后离开了。现在，你知道吗？他们有权这么做，因为以游戏的名义，我无论如何都该把她的东西还给她。但在那时，我太愤怒了，因为她竟然想回归过去。因为她曾一直说她很高兴没有那种传统的皮条客与妓女关系，她不再想参与其中。但她教会我的是，她渴望那种生活。她实际上确实想念它。
So you think she just lost respect for you as a pimp since you didn't care about any of that?
所以你认为她只是因为你不关心那些事而对你失去了身为皮条客的尊重？
I think so. Yeah, I think so. I think at some point, she needed somebody who held those values that she held higher than what I held them. As I was telling you, I didn't care if she brought $100 home. And I think when she started to realize that I didn't care, that was so much a part of her self-esteem. She always prided herself in her ability to make money that way. And yeah, I think she started to say, "[BLEEP], this [BLEEP], he don't give a [BLEEP]. He don't give a [BLEEP] about me." That my not caring about the money, for me, translated into me not caring about her, to her.
我想是的。是的，我想是的。我想在某个时刻，她需要一个像她那样看重那些价值观的人，而不是我这样。就像我告诉你的，我不在乎她带不带100美元回家。我认为当她开始意识到我不在乎时，而那又是她自尊心的很大一部分。她总是以自己那种赚钱的能力为傲。是的，我想她开始说：“妈的，这个烂货，他根本不在乎。他根本不在乎我。”我不在乎钱，对我来说，意味着我不在乎她。
Were you heartbroken?
你当时心碎了吗？
At the time, yeah. It was tough.
当时，是的。很难受。
After Lois, Kevin had a few other girls. But his heart wasn't in it. He just wasn't a very good pimp, and they knew it too. And eventually, they left him.
在洛伊斯之后，凯文还有过几个女孩。但他已经无心经营了。他根本不是个好的皮条客，她们也知道。最终，她们都离开了他。
For girls would had been around and who had been with guys who were pimps, they would soon find that I didn't feel that need in them, in terms of being able to control them or even having a desire to, in terms of how a raw pimp would handle them. And so as a result, I would either get rid of them or they would get rid of me. One of the two.
对于那些一直在周围、曾经和皮条客在一起的女孩，她们很快会发现我并没有那种需求，即控制她们的欲望，甚至没有那种原始皮条客对待她们的欲望。因此，结果就是，要么我赶走她们，要么她们离开我。两者必居其一。
Finally, after few years, Kevin got out of the game. By then, it was almost the '80s and pimping was dying. The vice cops I spoke to said women's lib killed off the pimps. They couldn't stand it anymore, giving all their money to a man. Kevin said it was a combination of that and crack cocaine that did in the '70s pimp.
最终，几年后，凯文退出了这场游戏。那时已经快到80年代了，拉皮条行业正在走向没落。我采访的风化案警察说，妇女解放运动终结了皮条客。她们再也无法忍受把所有的钱都交给一个男人了。凯文说这是妇女运动和快克可卡因共同导致了70年代皮条客的终结。
Crack cocaine sets you down. When you smoke that stuff, you have no desire to go anywhere. It's almost like you're embalmed. It starts to also trickle down from the pimps to the girls. Because now, their guy, who they had all their self-esteem in, is looking up at all this time, is now sitting in the house. He's just not the same person that he was once before. He's not riding. He's not fun like he used to be. He's not excited anymore. He don't have this whole god complex of being I'm still great and this and that.
快克可卡因让你彻底堕落。当你抽那玩意儿时，你哪儿都不想去。就像你被防腐处理过了一样。它也开始从皮条客层级渗透到女孩们身上。因为现在，她们引以为傲、寄托所有自尊的男人，正瘫在那儿，坐在这个房子里。他已经不是以前的那个人了。他不出来活动了。他不再像以前那样有趣。他不再兴奋了。他不再有那种上帝情结，觉得自己很了不起之类的了。
Every one of these guys that I'm telling you about got involved with crack cocaine. Every single one of them. And eventually, they lost all control. It took out many a pimp. Many a pimp.
我跟你说的每一个人都沾上了快克可卡因。每一个。最终，他们失去了所有的控制力。这摧毁了许多皮条客。许多皮条客。
Did any of them realize as it was happening that this was a downward spiral?
当事情发生时，他们之中有没有人意识到这是一个下行螺旋？
No. Not a single person ever stopped to think, "Well, you know what? Maybe this game is getting old. Maybe it's getting antiquated. Maybe it's time--" they always thought they were coming back. They were coming back. They were always one ho away from coming back, from being on top of the game.
没有。没有一个人停下来想：“好吧，你知道吗？也许这个游戏太老了。也许它过时了。也许是时候——”他们总以为自己会东山再起。他们会回来的。他们总是距离重回巅峰、统治游戏只差一个妓女。
I think the guys who were smart, who aspire to something better, they will always have used the game as a means to getting somewhere else. And that was very clear. But for the guys who were purely in the game for the game itself and felt from day one that the pimping was all they wanted to do, that's all they ever did. They lived it, they'll die it. Simple as that.
我认为那些聪明、渴望得到更好结果的人，总是会利用这个游戏作为通往其他地方的手段。这一点很清楚。但对于那些纯粹为了游戏本身而入行，从第一天起就觉得拉皮条是他们唯一想做的事情的人来说，那就是他们所做的一切。他们为它而生，也会为它而死。就是这么简单。
Still, like I said, it's about the purity and the love and the truth of the game. And that's the thing that-- I always loved that. I always understood the purity by which they approached what they did and their pure love of it. I always admired that, and I still do to this day. I still love the purity of which they loved it, and they studied it. They studied it, and they elevated it to an art form.
尽管如此，就像我说的，关键在于这种纯粹、爱以及游戏的真实性。这是那一点——我一直很喜欢。我一直理解他们对待所做之事时的纯粹性以及他们对它的纯爱。我一直钦佩这一点，直到今天。我仍然热爱他们对它倾注的那种纯粹的爱，他们研究它。他们研究它，并将其提升为一种艺术形式。
Kevin, today, makes his living in the straight world creating jewelry for rap stars. He spoke with Tamar Brott in California.
凯文如今在正常社会以制作说唱明星珠宝为生。他在加利福尼亚州接受了塔玛·布罗特的采访。
Our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself, with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Jorge Just, Todd Bachmann, and Sylvia Lemus.
今天的节目由我和阿利克斯·斯皮格尔制作，南希·厄普代克和朱莉·斯奈德共同参与。特约编辑：保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林以及顾问萨拉·沃威尔。制作协助：豪尔赫·贾斯特、托德·巴赫曼和西尔维娅·莱姆斯。
[ACKNOLWEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Musical advice from R.J. Smith. To buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312- 832-3380. Or visit our website where you can buy tapes, or you could also listen to our programs for free online, www.thisamericanlife.org. Special bonus tracks on the website this week. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
音乐顾问：R.J.史密斯。如需购买本节目或我们任何节目的录音带，请拨打我们芝加哥WBEZ的电话：312-832-3380。或者访问我们的网站购买磁带，您也可以在网上免费收听我们的节目：www.thisamericanlife.org。本周网站上有特别奖励曲目。《美国生活》由公共广播国际分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who knew that I would be a perfect public radio employee when he sidled up to me in a bar one night, years ago, and demanded--
WBEZ管理监督：托里·马拉蒂亚。他很早就知道我会成为一名完美的公共电台员工，因为多年前的一个晚上，他在一家酒吧侧身靠近我，要求——
Buy me a drink.
给我买杯酒。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。